hi everyone welcome to the homeroom live
stream sal here from khan academy i'm
excited about our conversation today
with dan roth editor-in-chief of
linkedin a lot to talk about on both the
future of work and a lot on just the
future of media too i think will be a
really interesting conversation so start
thinking of your questions and putting
them in the message boards wherever you
happen to be seeing this and we're going
to surface as many of the questions as
possible to dan but before we do that i
will make my standard announcements
first of all a reminder that we are not
for profit we can only exist with your
philanthropic donations so if you're in
a position to do so please think about
going to khan academy.org donate
also want to make a special shout out to
several organizations that stepped up
during covet especially many of them
were supporting us even before kovid but
when we saw that our costs had gone up
we were a lot more folks were dependent
on khan academy and continued to be
special thanks to bank of america
google.org att fastly and novartis and
the many other funders and supporters of
khan academy pre and during covid and
hopefully postcovid as well we need your
help we continue to need your help we
have a gap for 2021.
also quick reminder you can get a
version of this live stream homeroom
with sal the podcast wherever you get
your podcasts
so with that i'm excited to introduce
dan roth dan good to see you
great to see you thanks for having me on
so maybe the first thing just to get
everyone acquainted i think most people
know about linkedin
and i think most folks you know at the
high level it's kind of the social
network for business they view it as a
place where you can look for jobs find
jobs find interesting things that are
going on in the business world
why does linkedin have
a editor-in-chief what is it what do you
do
it's a great question uh and i ask
myself that all the time so i've been at
linkedin for
almost 10 years now nine and a half
years i joined linkedin
when
linkedin was moving from being a place
to connect professionals with each other
to being a place that serves as a way
for people to connect to economic
opportunity
and at the time before joining linkedin
i was a long time
writer and editor at fortune wired
forbes it helped start a magazine called
conde nast portfolio which was a
business magazine started by conde nast
and had always been a
business journalist just trying to
explain to the world how and to
professionals how business worked
um
at the time linkedin
jeff weiner who was the ceo of linkedin
uh was thinking about the next evolution
of linkedin this thinking was that if we
are going to
uh serve the mission of linkedin which
is not just to connect people but to
help make them better what they do or
what they want to do we do that by
helping them stay informed and helping
make sure that they are building their
own voice
and
the way that you do that is through
getting them the right news at the right
time and then getting them to talk about
it and so to do that well you need an
editor
so he hired me and i built up a team we
have about 75 editors around the world
who
curate content cultivate new voices so
trying to find people who are uniquely
qualified to talk about certain things
and bring them on linkedin and then we
curate the uh the best of what we see so
curate cultivate create
uh these are mostly business journalists
like myself and we're just trying to
make sure that we are serving up high
quality information to people so that
when you come to linkedin
your time is spent uh
that it is a valuable use of your time
that if you are no matter what you do
for a living when you come to linkedin
you should find some news that's
interesting to you that helps you get
smarter what you're doing or helps you
make a connection or connect dots from
around the world and to do that well you
need editors and algorithms so we work
really closely with our relevance
engineers we make sure that we are
giving people what they want in their
world but also helping them helping pop
filter bubbles and make sure they are
seeing what is going on in the world
around them that's what i do
it's fascinating because it's a very
different take than some of the other
social media platforms obviously that
aren't quite as business focused but if
you take a twitter if you take a
facebook
you know the news is in theory all user
generated and they have increasingly
felt hold under scrutiny of hey what if
someone posts something that is you know
inciting violence or is just inaccurate
and so they're having to do a little bit
more policing function but they're
definitely not creating their own
content what
what why do you think linkedin has gone
down this path and what do you think has
been the pros and cons of doing that
sure uh
the
um
one of the it is important to us that
when people come to linkedin they know
that this is a
place where they can trust what they see
linkedin if you look at the business
insider does a survey every year
of social of trust in social media
linkedin for i don't know four years
running three four years running is the
number one
uh most trusted social media site
the way that we
do that and the way that we maintain it
is by one making sure we have real
identities when you come to linkedin you
were coming with your
professional identity you were saying
who you work for who you who you have
worked for in the past and then we are
connecting you with your colleagues who
can vouch for your talk about what
you're good at also
when you come to your feed you should
have a feeling that just like you're
seeing real people that you're seeing
real news and information on there so we
have always
believed that it is important to have an
editorial voice and an editorial
perspective on linkedin
so for instance with the latest election
if you went to if you go if you open
your app right now and you go to your
notifications tab you'll see something
at the top that says um
the 2020 election latest on the 2020
election if you click there if this is
for if you're in the u.s i should i
should say if you click there you'll end
up with on a on a page that is created
and curated by editors that says here is
exactly what is going on with the
election this is trusted information
from trusted sources uh and we ran this
all the way through the entire through
the election process
and it's still up there today it is
important that for if you are no matter
what you do if you come to linkedin that
you have that one place to go to get
that information and say here's here's
what's going on in the world i can trust
what i'm seeing here
you asked about ugc user generated
content is the heart and soul of
linkedin we are what we create as
editors is a drop in the bucket
versus what our members create every
single day through their articles and
their posts videos uh images that
they're putting up on linkedin
they are talking to their world about
what's going on around them and what
they're what they're seeing and we as
editors are trying to get more and more
of that content from them so we'll reach
out every day to people who are
who might be
in the news whether they know it or not
so let's say for instance that
there's a big merger going on we could
reach out to people who are in that
industry saying can you explain what you
know spotify is buying megaphone can you
talk about what this means for the
future of podcasting
and people who are in the podcasting
business would get this alert and they
might say like oh yeah i have something
that i am qualified to talk about that i
want to share there's something that's
in the back of my head that i've talked
to my colleagues about but if i can
share with the world maybe something
maybe an even better conversation
happens and so we get them to share that
on linkedin
and then just uh i think the last point
is that you asked about like how this is
different
the big difference is that we're a
professional social
media site
what you write here is seen by your boss
and your colleagues and your future
colleagues and people who you might want
to work for you one day when you start
your own business
all of that
increases the
uh i think i think for a lot of us
sharing on social is always worrisome
but when you come to linkedin you know
there's that extra concern what is my
boss going to say when they when they
see what i've written what are my
employees going to say
and
so we as editors can help guide people
to say this is a topic that is worth
weighing in on people are hungry to hear
from you on this thing that's going on
in the news and this is a safe thing to
talk about
so i think unlike some other social
media where you might fire it up and
talk about whatever you feel like
talking about there's an extra level of
concern and seriousness uh that takes
place on linkedin because of the
professional profile
i'm curious and i definitely want to
talk about uh the future of work which i
know is another area that you have a lot
of expertise but you know this whole
notion of social media and
misinformation is such a hot topic it
does seem like linkedin has threaded the
needle quite well of having a lot of
user generated content also having some
editorially curated content and also
just by the nature of it being real
identities et cetera everything you
mentioned seems like you're doing a good
job
what do you think is the future of some
of the other social media platforms i
mean i i actually you know i thought a
lot about this issue i don't i don't
have a simple solution for
you know how do you balance people being
able to put ideas out there while some
ideas are from russian bots or
just people who are trying to put out
misinformation where do you think this
is going to go
uh i don't
i you know i wish i knew i i think that
there is i can tell you that my own
beliefs about what's important for us to
figure out in the social media landscape
is how do we make sure that there is
that there are real identities behind
everything that i think that there is
one of the the key drivers to
linkedin's success has been this idea
that you
have to
stand for what you are saying and that
doesn't there are some people that don't
mind saying crazy
things and knowing that it's on their
real identity that is always going to
happen but it definitely raises the bar
and and it adds a lot of um
it it it should make you think twice
about what it is that you're saying so i
think that's really important and i
think that what the social media other
social media sites are doing in terms of
labeling content is really important i
think the role of fact checkers
is important and i hope that social
media sites keep investing in in those
areas um
and then i guess the last thing i would
say is that i think that um i watch how
my kids use social
and it's very different
than uh than the way i think older
generations use social they go into it
with a certain understanding that of of
what it's for and what it's not for i
want to take it seriously and when not
to take it seriously and also i think
when to hop off
um and and i wonder if this generation
that has grown up with social as being
the primary way that they are
uh not just getting information but
building their voice
has a better handle on uh on what
they're seeing there that because they
are also the ones putting up jokey
content that they can record that they
can recognize when someone is trolling
because maybe they're trolling
themselves also um and so i do think
there will be a change in how
people
and how damaging social can be
uh
or the the downsides when people have
much more information or or
intrinsically get uh what the weaknesses
are with what they might be seeing on
certain sites where there is no
anonymity where anyone could post
anything and where people are saying
stuff just to get a rise out of you
yeah yeah and i hope i hope you're right
i hope the next generation i mean we've
had guests on before talking about that
this generation that's growing up on
social media all of the negatives that
it might have but they might also be
building some skill sets so you know
pivoting a little bit we're obviously in
the midst of a covid crisis
you know it looks like you're working
from home i'm working from home yeah um
what what's
what's your view
uh you know what are you seeing linkedin
what are you doing in reporting what's
your view that you're having of the
future of of work um you know and covet
especially how it might impact that
uh i think that
um
it's a big question and i think there
are a lot of different ways to to look
at it
the there are certain industries that we
have seen through our data that are just
getting absolutely um
that are that are in such serious pain
that i think it's hard to think about
how they come back
um and
there are others that are doing
extremely well what are the ones that
you think might have trouble coming back
well i think leisure and hospitality are
it's going to be a long time before they
come back and there could be a point
where
coming back is no longer an option
because you have lost years of knowledge
of you've had to cut to the bone you
have lost people's
what people how people spend their money
and what they do in their leisure time
has changed so i think it's going to be
years before
business travel comes back
and because i think we're all learning
how to
do these kind of calls from home there
was a um
i think it was the ceo of infosys
massive
uh
indian
outsourcing
i.t firm that said look i used to get on
a a plane and fly
and and i would fly to the u.s for a
five million dollar deal now we're
closing two billion dollar deals over
over vc over these kind of calls
one you realize you have to do that you
don't have to go pack a bag you don't
have to get trapped in an airplane for
eight hours you don't have to deal with
jet lag going back to that's really
difficult
and so i was talking to i do an
interview series also on linkedin i was
talking to david chang the founder of
momofuku yesterday and he's a giant
restaurateur and he says look without
business travel
restaurants don't come back we rely on
that lunch traffic and that breakfast
traffic to be able to
pay for so much else of what goes on in
the restaurant in the restaurant world
it's not just leisure dinners and so you
start seeing these downstream impacts
where a lot of leisure and travel
don't come back if business travel
doesn't come back cruises when do
cruises come back i think that's going
to be a long time so anything that
involves us getting together uh in
person i think will take uh will take a
while to come back and we'll come back
in a different form what we've seen on
linkedin is the people who are in those
industries are are very
actively trying to get out of those
industries they realize that there is a
need to
find a path that takes you from
uh this area into something else
and
and and i think that's accelerating um
you know
i don't know if you've had professor
galloway on your scott galloway on your
show before but he he has this theory
that what covett is doing is just
accelerating trends that were already in
the works
so
virtual uh big tech getting bigger
and i would add to that this kind of
skills based
workforce this idea that what you do is
a collection of
what you do is really a collection of
skills
versus you being an expert in one
particular job so as an example of that
like you could be a great travel um you
might be a great i don't know a
person in travel you might be able to
travel
anything in travel you have to just
think about what the what the atomized
set of skills are that that make up your
job and then where else you could apply
those skills
i think my favorite example of this is i
was talking to someone at a insurance
company
who said that
when
they look for insurance adjusters people
that can that can work with um
with people around their around their
accidents and try to understand what
happened and who's at fault and whatever
else goes into being an insurance
adjuster
this this executive said we hire
bartenders
because bartenders have this ability to
get
to get people to tell their stories
and i think if you're a bartender you
don't think of yourself as being a
story aggregator but that's a skill it's
a skill to get people to talk and once
you start thinking of your work in terms
of what are the skills that go into what
do i do versus i identify myself as a
bartender you the world starts opening
up to you and i think that is
accelerated by kovid is people realizing
that they are that they've built their
careers on potentially shaky ground and
that if they are going to continue to
work it is going to come from being able
to hop from industry to industry and job
to job and it's your skills that will
enable you to do that
and what do you think about the
in-person workplace what do you think
about you know out here in silicon
valley some people say oh
you know commercial real estate's gonna
die other people say no it might be
bigger than ever because people need
more space
where do you fall on that debate
uh all right so this is just a personal
take but i think that it is a uh i think
it's a mistake to write off personal
interactions i think the workplace might
change and how we what we do in work
it'll become a lot more flexible
um
but i don't think i think that this need
for
human interaction and the kind of
ideas that come through serendipity
through bumping into someone into a
hallway through the meeting that takes
place after the meeting you know some of
the best projects we've ever done that
i've been involved with have come
because the meeting is over and a few of
us stay in the conference room and all
of a sudden someone gets up to a white
board it says you know actually what if
we do it this way and you're like oh
yeah that's exactly the way we should do
it and and off you go
um when you are doing these kind of
teams or zoom calls one half hour half
hour half hour which is how a lot of us
are working it's how i'm working right
now you lose that spontaneity
and i think there is a real uh there's a
real benefit for that and i think that
we're really missing it so this morning
i got a chance to go on a walking
meeting
with someone who i haven't met before
and we were planning on getting together
it was the first time i've done it since
march we met in prospect park and i'm
based in new york we met in prospect
park in brooklyn and we walked side by
side our mass on and it was for 45
minutes we just talked about
questions questions that that she had
about how to do something in her job
and it was great and it was a it was a
free-flowing conversation in a way that
i have not experienced in a long time
and i think that that is something that
once we start getting that again it's
going to be hard to give it up
so i don't i am not a i don't i'm not a
believer in the full and that everyone
goes virtual i just don't think it's
sustainable
yeah maybe some type of hybrid more
flexible i do want to double click on uh
the the air travel thing uh because
those folks have watched this in the
past know that myself and planes have
not had a good history together
uh and
and if you know even from in my job
obviously i have to travel a lot
sometimes speak sometimes you know
fundraise and to your point i actually
find that i'm able to have more
efficient and effective fundraising
meetings with potential donors right now
than before with all of that overhead
and it creates you know it's not good
for the environment it's not good for
people's health right et cetera et
cetera can we start a movement
to never travel again
i mean we should travel to see our
families and you know that type of thing
go on vacation see the world but you
know this business travel let me go
cross country for a meeting
and then you know slept back
yeah it seems like you're working to do
that let's start a linkedin movement i'm
with you i'm part of that linkedin
movement there is no doubt
um i think that you know going back to
your last question though i do think
that the
it's it is easier to have that kind of
pledge right now when we're all acting
when we're all in this world
once
there is a big enough shift towards in
person everything goes in person so i do
think there's some kind of network
effect that kind of happens when you
just don't want to feel left out right
now there is no you can't have fomo
today there is no place where there is
no room where it happens anymore um it
is a series of these small rooms
virtually connected once that room where
it happens idea comes back we're going
to talk we're going to start getting
back it's the pull to get back on the
plane it's going to start happening
again but i'm with you i got to say the
one uh surprising upside of this is
um you know there are not to say that
any of this is an upside this is this is
a horrible uh situation and
a world we are living in right now
because of covid
um but i'm spending way more time with
my family and it's really nice to not be
on the plane every other week so i i'm
not looking forward to going back to
that
no and you know we could say that that's
a nice to have from just like your own a
personal contentment point of view but i
believe having that time with your
family having a better family life
connecting with your kids with your
partner that's going to make you a
better more effective at work and to
your earlier point you can do more in
that same amount of time it takes to go
cross country do one meeting and come
back you could do 10 meetings
which will be far less completing anyway
i'll get off of we'll we'll go offline
and think about how we can
and you know i have deep sympathy for it
for these industries and hopefully
there's ways for them to pivot but you
know i've never it has never made sense
to me uh and it it seems to make
everyone i'm talking to they're like
yeah my life is so much better now that
i don't have to travel all the time
right okay let's sign a pact right now
right that's never gonna be you know
it's bad it's bad for the environment it
really is i mean yeah
it's it's horrible um so a lot of
questions that are that are coming in
uh so one question i'll modify a little
bit from smartbear on youtube
how do you think linkedin has grown in
the past five years and what do you
think it's going to look like five years
from now
uh
the
number one way i would say it's grown is
in terms of this explosion of
a professional voice on linkedin
that
the uh this idea of sharing what you
know
or sharing what you don't know and
saying and being open and vulnerable and
saying i have questions about how to do
x or i don't understand why why is
happening
that was very different um years ago it
was hard to convince people to
write and share on linkedin under their
professional identity which we talked
about
it's not it's no longer hard i think
people still have to think about it but
it makes sense to them and i think that
a younger generation especially thinks
of it as a
given
that
their that their voice needs to be heard
that creating is part of who they are
um
and i think that's a great thing this
idea of democratizing voice is something
that i think is is one of the best
things to happen
so before when i was a
traditional journalist and um and i
worked for
when i was doing a story for fortune i
would pick up the phone and
i might make 100 phone calls for an
article and then i would quote two
people
and i would have benefited from those 98
other phone calls and learning how an
industry works or what's going on behind
the scenes but my readers never got to
see any of that they would see it all
filtered through my eyes but they never
got the direct experience of those
quotes from these experts
what we're seeing on linkedin now is
this is an outpouring of people who are
experts or want to develop an expertise
who are sharing what they know which
helps all of us get smarter faster um so
that's that's probably been the biggest
uh the biggest change and i think it
mirrors if you look at the thing that
edelman the pr firm does something
called the edelman trust barometer every
year where they measure the uh entities
and institutions that people trust today
it's a it's a great read you should go
check it out
the the number one uh most trusted
entity
today is my ceo
the people say my then is subject matter
experts and there's been this drop in
trust in government and in in the media
but people believe in the people who are
signing their paychecks and they believe
in people who have some skin in the game
and they want to hear more from them and
this and what we're seeing is that these
executives these subject matter experts
these people who are just coming up are
sharing this information on linkedin so
that's the biggest in terms of what i
think we'll see in the next five years
this kind of skills development is that
we touched on i think is going to be a
massive part in what people use linkedin
for as you come to linkedin you come to
develop skills you use linkedin learning
to get skilled up in
how to do facebook ads or how to learn r
or anything plato learned python
and and you put on your profile that you
have developed that skill and for um for
recruiters being able to see that you
know john smith has a skill in
this area that we need
is an instant validator in a way that
they haven't had before and so that kind
of skill development at getting putting
skills on your profile showing off what
you know and how you've learned it and
then continuing to build off this and
and how you think which means like how
the the postings and uh and articles
that people are publishing that to me
creates this explosion of um
of of information on linkedin
that enables people to change jobs or
find better jobs or
have the kind of careers they want to
have that are dependent on uh where they
can guide it themselves so that's what i
think is going to happen
yeah that makes it makes a ton of sense
and related to that this question from
facebook maria aguim asks
what advice can i give my high schoolers
graduating this year who are unsure
about what major or field to look into
given given all the change that we're
talking
about great question all right so i
would say number one
is this is this has been true for years
that the most in-demand skill that we
have heard from
uh
from hiring managers is
uh is the ability to
um communicate communication skills are
the number one thing that hiring
managers are looking for and especially
in a world like this where we are all
behind our computers or writing on
google docs or however else we're
communicating uh this ability to
to be able to um to communicate clearly
and consistently is important so i tell
so tell your your
your high schooler number one make sure
that you are learning how to write that
you are very clear in in
that you're taking english lessons that
you're that you are spending a lot of
time um
learning how to communicate and just be
great just be a great communicator
that's number one number two if you want
to look at the jobs of the
of the uh the future
um we were just looking at so i'm just
pulling this up right now we looked at
we did a look at what are some of the
jobs where we know that that that there
is a contin that there there's outsized
demand and we expect that kind of
outsized demand to continue so software
developer
sales representative project manager i.t
administration i.t administrator digital
marketer um i t support help desk
basically anything if you can be
anything around how to make sure that
people are
we know that the tech techno technology
is underpinning every single company
today every company is a tech company
you want to have those kind of tech
skills
so i think that an engineering degree is
always always makes sense uh it might
not be for everyone but if you can't if
that is an area that you are have any
interest in
learning how to be an engineer is is a
great thing to do
otherwise sales is always really great
there's always going to be a need for
someone for for for doing sales but if
your teenager
high school grad doesn't know what he or
she wants to do just make sure that they
are learning how to communicate that is
the key and the number two is make sure
that they are flexible that they learn
how to
ride the waves because
the kind of
of change we see in industries today is
not going to slow down and being able to
um adapt to
to the to situations around you is going
to be so important and being able to
take whatever you've learned and then
adapt it and go somewhere else you got
to know how to do that that's probably
more important than any
major that you could have today in
college is just understanding how to
adapt and how to stay flexible that's
what i would say
if you are 22 years old maybe you have
an engineering degree maybe you have a
lot of degree
oh
can you hear me now i can't hear you
oh
well we're at the home stretch anyway um
it might be me
i don't know we see what the
well i think it's me
all right can you hear me
gotham
oh going on let me let me let me write
you a note well i don't know felipe if
you could tell dan to just you know any
farting thoughts for folks if you can
hear me i can't hear anything
unfortunately but this is part of this
stay adaptable so i'll tell you what i'm
going to do i'm going to put my phone
number into this private chat that we
have if you're watching this i don't
think you can see this i hope not
otherwise everyone's getting my phone
number and if you want to call maybe we
can do it this way
or you can write out your questions and
i'll answer them
all right let's see the chat
while we do this can i just say
something i'm gonna now i'm just gonna
monologue uh i will say that we have
that we
that on linkedin we keep a running list
of jobs that are hiring uh there are
places that are hiring right now so this
is not it might feel like that no one is
actually hiring uh there are companies
that are doing it targeting amazon ups
fedex mcdonald's albertsons dollar
general there are big companies that are
trying to hire that that are continuing
to hire even this pandemic
and um
and i did want to talk about a survey
that we did recently that might be
interesting which is we looked at people
who had lost their jobs and we talked to
hiring man recruiters and hiring
managers about what they were looking
for
and a really interesting piece of data
came out there two interesting pieces of
data came out of this
one is that people who've lost their
jobs are uh
incredibly ashamed and embarrassed that
they've lost their jobs 46 percent said
they have lied about being unemployed
and
what and then when we talked to hiring
managers they said they don't
care whether someone is unemployed or
not it makes no difference to them in
terms of hiring on whether someone is
currently employed so there's this
incredible mismatch in how people think
about their uh their work
and
what uh and what companies are looking
for that if you don't have a job it's
okay not to have a job
what hiring managers just want to know
is that you are continuing to stay busy
that you're trying new things you're
developing new skills that you're
continuing to post and share and
explaining who you are
um but it's not something to hide from
and i think that for a long time we have
been led to believe that
you can only get a job if you currently
have a job or that you need to
put on a fake front and make it seem
like you're still working it's just not
true the data says that this is not true
that you can
that that having a job is not the most
important thing to getting your next job
it is staying active showing that you're
still involved that you are doing things
that are productive and that you are
someone that a company can get
meaningful work out of right as soon as
they hire you
and i'm assuming you can't hear me
no
well what i will say is
i hope thank you
for joining
thank you um
yeah
and uh
we will do this again
i'm trying to see how how i can
communicate with you
so i think we're all good
so i don't know if all of y'all can hear
me um my apologies for the the technical
difficulties near the end uh but thanks
everyone for joining great conversation
with dan i hope we can bring him on
again because i had a ton more questions
although we did get pretty close to
running out of time but thanks everyone
for uh joining tomorrow we're going to
have marley diaz arthur and founder of
pound 1000 black girl books uh so we're
looking forward to having her on and any
questions you might have please please
bring her on uh please please uh bring
those questions to us but with that
thanks for joining today's live stream i
will see you all soon
you